etes-vous obéissant êtes-vous soumis non
ça c'est ce que vous croyez
et c'est ce qu'on croyait aussi avant
milgram salue aujourd'hui pour ce jeudi
du hors sujet je voulais vous parler de
l'expérience de milgram entre 1960 1963
milgram et son équipe ont créé et
réalisé un test de psychologie visant à
mesurer le degré d'obéissance des gens
le principe était très simple il fallait
justifier une action en se référant à
une autorité pour l'expérience il ya
toujours trois personnes la personne qui
prenait le rôle du chercheur
scientifique et donc il représentait
l'autorité la victime qui était un
comédien un complice je vais vous
expliquer à quoi elles servent et et le
sujet c'est à dire la personne testée
qui perpétraient les actions il ya deux
choses à savoir important tout le monde
se rencontrer au départ et tirer au sort
qui allait à voir quel rôle parmi la
personne qui disait les réponses et la
personne qui allait envoyer des
décharges
oui ils s'envoyaient des décharges
électriques le tirage au sort était
bidon il était pipeauté puisqu'on
voulait que le sujet soit celui qui
envoie les décharges
et la deuxième chose à savoir c'est
qu'ils étaient défrayer mais il n'y
avait rien à gagner il n'y avait pas de
gain pour la personne qui était le sujet
en clair il n'y avait pas de récompense
au fait qu'ils fassent les actions et y
avait pas de représailles si jamais il
décidait de ne plus les faire c'est très
important de comprendre ça parce qu'on
comprend même temps qui avait pas de
vraie pression extérieure y avait pas
une pression du gard n'y avait pas une
pression de masse via la foule y avait
pas une peur des représailles
c'était dans son libre arbitre qu'il
faisait les actions la victime se
mettait dans une autre pièce et elle
devait répondre à une série de questions
le sujet lui était devant une machine où
ils allaient envoyer des décharges
électriques
c'est à dire qu'à chaque mauvaise
réponse de l'autre personne qui était
comédien mais lui ne le savaient pas le
sujet devait envoyer en punition une
décharge électrique eu le nombre de
mauvaises réponses accumulé plus les
décharges électriques étaient fort pour
aller jusqu'à une dose mortelle de 460
volts et histoire de rajouter un petit
peu au fur et à mesure de l'expérience
quand la personne se prenaient des
décharges en tout cas six minutes se
prendrait des charges on l'entendait
hurler et demandé à ce que ça s'arrête
sachant que la personne qui envoie les
décharges ne subira pas de représailles
n'a rien à gagner donc rien à gagner et
rien à perdre est-ce qu'elle va
continuer à faire ça ou pas comme ils g
en a parlé à des psychologues de
l'époque on lui a dit il ya peut-être un
ou deux pourcent des personnes qui vont
aller jusqu'à 150 volts c'est beaucoup
plus que ça tous les participants sans
exception sont allés au moins jusqu'à
135 volts avant d'arrêter mais sans vous
donner tous les détails 62 5 % des gens
tester 62 5% c'est énorme sont allés
jusqu'au bout jusqu'au 460 volts ce qui
représente l autorité c'était donc le
chercheur qui me
à bien le test il n'avait le droit de
dire que quatre phrases si la personne
souhaitait arrêter sa première phrase
c'était continuer s'il vous plaît cette
simple phrase là dans la majorité des
cas a fait que la personne a continué
tout le long si la personne demandé une
deuxième fois à s'arrêter
le chercheur avait juste le droit de
dire l'expérience exige que vous
continuez si dans le test la personne de
demander une troisième fois d'arrêter
il devait dire il est absolument
indispensable que vous continuez c'est
vraiment les phrases précise et exacte
enfin un mot avant pas un mot après pas
de discussions il y avait que ces quatre
phrases et la dernière fois c'était vous
n'avez pas le choix veuillez continuer
si la 4e phrase la personne disait non
vraiment j'ai pas envie alors
l'expérience s'arrêter là c'était bon et
sinon la seule manière d'arrêter c'était
d'aller jusqu'aux 450 460 volts qui est
un choc électrique pouvoir être
considérée comme mortelle 62,5 pour cent
des gens qui se réfère à une autorité
quelle qu'elle soit juste parce qu'il
lui prête un pouvoir et se crée une
pression eux mêmes c'est déjà beaucoup
on s'est posé la question il ya quelques
années est ce que ça pouvait être encore
le cas aujourd'hui d'une émission télé
qualité fait là dessus qu'il ya un
projet franco suisse j'ai retrouvé la
vidéo de cette émission je vous la met
dans le descriptif ils ont réessayé
l'expérience de milgram mais version jeu
télé durant des semaines et des semaines
ils ont fait un plateau télé qui est
essentiel est un plat de ce test avec
toujours le même tirage au sort le
joueur dans la cabine qui prenait les
décharges et celui qui les envoyaient
toutes les personnes qui ont participé
savais que c'était un casting test et
qu'il n'avait rien à gagner
donc encore une fois il n'y avait rien à
perdre rien à gagner en 1960 62 5 % des
gens sont allés au bout et il ya
quelques années seulement dont se jeter
les 81 % des personnes sont allées au
bout c'est à dire que si on mettait en
scène le jeu de la mort réellement à la
télé les gens iraient au bout encore une
fois n'hésitez pas à regarder la vidéo
je vous mets le lien dans le descriptif
elle est très intéressante elle est
passionnante ça dure une heure et demie
mais ça vaut le coup au final milgram il
nous aura appris une chose c'est pas
qu'il faut forcément défier l'autorité
ou les autorités en général mais il faut
au moins garder son esprit critique pour
remettre en cause l'autorité et remettre
en cause le bien fondé en clair c'est
pas parce qu'on vous dit de le faire
qu'il faut forcément le faire sans
réfléchir à pourquoi on fait merci
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo j'espère que
ça vous a intéressé que ça vous a plu
si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à mettre
un pouce en l'air allez-y faites le il
est indispensable que vous fassiez oui
et puis du coup personne ne le met pas
ce que vous voulez défier l'autorité
n'hésitez pas non plus à laisser un
commentaire je les lis tous toujours
évidemment vous pouvez également vous
abonner à la chaîne puisque le mental
blog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un
an
donc rendez vous
demain à 17h ciao